hey guys what's up my name is scottysire
I make music and I try very hard to be
in the books it doesn't always work out
for me though today I'm taking a which
member of the vlog squad quiz to see who
I am in the vlogs good first things
first
how would your friends describe you I
have loyal responsible funny mysterious
chill obnoxious I think I'm all of these
things probably most of my friends would
consider me chill because I just kind of
chill take an iconic vine to watch on
repeat that usually tell me I look like
SH Alyssa is that weed to bros chillin
in a hot tub roadwork ahead fresher Baca
- [ __ ] your chicken strips this one's
tough I love buying I think my favorite
and like the most quotable one for me
was chicken strips er how do I can't
even do it but like that one's funny
get chicken strips I think that was
closer she was a youtuber to collab with
Tana mojo James Charles Djou Josie WA
jake paul emma Chamberlayne glozell I
think Tana would be funny to collaborate
with just because she's like so just
like out there very like not kooky but
like she just like makes things happen
choose a side hustle everyone has one Oh
music of course I do music so there was
other options though podcast author
stand-up comedian model personal trainer
I can really kind of feel what all of
these would be like podcasts would maybe
be like David or Jason author Todd
stand-up comedy Jason model Jeff
personal trainer Jeff not me I think I'm
definitely going with music choose
another vlog squad member to be stuck on
a deserted island with zing not saying
Todd Keith Carly Josh or Erin I think
the most crafty of the crew and the most
like outdoorsy would probably be heat so
I'd have to go with Heath started
everyone else I just I don't trust you I
just associate Zane with like watching
tic TOCs and spending a really long time
on the toilet so I don't know what
benefit I'd have with him there I'm on
an island with me choose a type of
YouTube channel mukbang makeup tutorials
story times drama channel DIY or vlogs I
think the only thing that I really watch
is vlogs and drama channels the only
thing that I would make our vlogs
because I don't like drama
finally choose a car for
David to buy you in his next video I got
his David outside is he gonna surprise
me with the car after this Tesla a
classic g-wagen car that Zane bought and
sold Ferrari Rolls Royce Mercedes
Bugatti I think I'd go with Rolls Royce
because it's like it hasn't been done
before for the blog and I want to be
different
you got scottysire you're too cool for
school
badass doesn't even begin to start to
describe you and your tude but below
that bad-boy exterior and those bleached
roots is someone with a heart of gold
I like this quiz yeah I think I'd have
to agree I don't think I'm very badass
to begin with but I like that that's my
image if if I have that kind of image I
do have a heart of gold
[Music]
you